well it's another day in the United
States and another several mass
shootings remember even when they don't
make the news there are typically a
number of mass shootings every day in
the United States yesterday there was
one that did make national news it took
place at the Covenant School which is a
Christian private school in Nashville
Tennessee as of right now we believe six
people were killed as well as the
shooter
three children three staff members were
among the Dead the shooter has been
identified as a 28 year old former
student killed by responding police
officers and very quickly the sum total
of the narrative from the American right
wing has become that the shooter was
trans and thus everything from drag
shows to gender affirming care are to
blame oh and psychiatric medications as
well
are to blame for what took place the
shooter had no criminal record and had
attended this school at an early age
according to The Tennessean the shooter
was a trans man who used male pronouns
and immediately this is the sort of uh
reaction that we get from anti-trans
activist Matt Walsh always remember what
happened at the Covenant School remember
what happened to those innocent victims
to those children we are facing a truly
demonic evil never forget that radical
republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
Greene says quote how much hormones like
testosterone and medications for mental
mental illness was the transgender
Nashville school shooter taking everyone
can stop blaming guns now Candace Owens
jumping into the mix saying when you
play Frankenstein with people's body
parts this is code for gender affirming
care that sometimes includes surgery
when you play Frankenstein with people's
body parts you can't be surprised when
they behave like Monsters a person
willing to execute violence upon his or
her own body will not hesitate to impart
violence onto someone else's linking I
guess gender dysphoria
to being violent against other people
which doesn't make any sense and has
never been demonstrated empirically Dan
bongino says quote because it has rarely
failed me I'm going to wait until I have
the details of the Nashville attack
before offering detailed comments
however after spending the past two
hours reading the absolutely grotesque
comments by leftists about this incident
and the attack on Rand Paul staffer a
sane person can only conclude that we're
dealing with demons on the left
if your sane says dan you would blame
demons there's no other explanation for
their evil none that's a very very
interesting take the now Infamous cat
turd right-wing account which has gotten
the publicity of Donald Trump reposting
their content captured posts they've
been grooming your children and now
they're shooting your children
seriously when are you going to stop
being afraid and start speaking out
against evil at what point do you stop
selling your soul to Cave to this woke
mob again groomers uh to blame Benny
Johnson uh from the right wing
organization uh TP USA Turning Point USA
tweeting three weeks ago Tennessee
banned child gender mutilation today a
transgender committed premeditated mass
murder hate crime against Christians
killing six including three little
children this was an act of demonic
Vengeance by a movement of mentally ill
domestic terrorists enough
and then Laverne Spicer tweeting the
anti-christian rhetoric in our nation
has now resulted in a school shooting in
Nashville Tennessee so a couple
different things here first and foremost
there is no evidence whatsoever
that drag shows
gender affirming care
demons or any of it are responsible for
this particular shooting
furthermore it is abundantly clear that
we aren't going to prevent shootings
with things like the stop woke Act of
Florida or Banning drag shows or Banning
the amorphous CRT which they seem unable
to explain even what it is or whether
it's even being taught in classes or any
of it we do have a whole bunch of
different ideas with regard to gun
safety
none of which the right wants to
implement which would certainly help
reduce the number of these incidents no
one as I've said before no one policy
would prevent every shooting and I've
talked about before and the Gun Show
loophole Universal background checks
mandatory waiting periods no high
capacity weapons under age 25 mandatory
gun Insurance required Community Support
letters if you're buying a gun and
you're under 25 ban some weapons
periodic mental health evaluations
extensive licensing process gun buyback
program all but David the gun buyback
program wouldn't have prevented that
shooting or Banning some weapons
wouldn't have prevented this shooting
that's right but all of these things
would prevent some shootings one other
note about this I posted a tweet
yesterday
um sort of calling out the fact that
despite continuing to ask for thoughts
and prayers and saying that part of the
problem we have is God has been taken
out of school I pointed out this
shooting happened at a Christian School
this was either deliberately or
accidentally misinterpreted by some as
me blaming the kids who were shot and of
course I would never do that
unfortunately I took that tweet down
because of the number of threats that
came in not only against me but against
members of my family people finding fit
my family's contact information and
going after them so I did delete the
Tweet the point I was making of course
was that Republicans who offer nothing
other than prayers
are unwilling to implement any of the
policies I just mentioned and continue
saying the problem isn't guns clearly
this was not an issue of that given that
it was a Christian school that is what I
meant unfortunately the threats are
raining down and I did delete that tweet
for those who are asking we will
continue talking about this let's
briefly take a detour into a mom who was
able to get in on a Fox News segment
um to say when are we going to actually
do something about the gun safety issue
so uh yesterday there was a um a press
briefing from Nashville PD after the
shooting at the Covenant School this
horrible event in which six people were
killed and the shooter also died and a
parent was actually able to get on air
which was fantastic and as The Daily
Beast writes a mother visiting Nashville
took to the Fox News Airwaves to call
out the country's lack of gun safety as
yet another mass shooting unfolded at a
Nashville school this was as reporters
and Crews were waiting for a police
press conference to start the woman has
been identified by local reporters as
Ashby Beasley
who herself survived the July 4 parade
in Highland Park Illinois and was a
block away from the Covenant School
yesterday here she is jumping in and
this is uh take a listen aren't you guys
tired of covering this
aren't you guys tired of being here and
having to cover all of these mass
shootings I'm from Highland Park
the audio briefly cuts out but then it
comes back
with my son visiting my sister-in-law I
have been lobbying in DC
since we survived a mass shooting in
July I have met with over 130 lawmakers
how is this still happening how are our
children still dying and why are we
failing them gun violence is the number
one killer of children and teens it has
overtaken cars assault weapons are
contributing to the Border crisis in
fentanyl we are arming cartels with our
guns and our Goose loose gun laws and
these shootings in these mass shootings
will continue to happen until our
lawmakers step up and pass gun safety
legislation yeah but instead they want
to pass laws about critical race Theory
books that need to be banned art that
needs to be banned history that can't be
taught sex education that can't be
taught they want to do everything other
than actually deal with what is at issue
here I'm pretty sure this was an
unsecured weapon that this teenager got
a hold of
the past gun safe to like say storage
laws in this country to protect kids
from getting a hold of weapons that they
shoot each other with
all right so uh we're gonna break away
there because that reporter who was
using that camera is uh obviously
setting up to do a live report there but
the woman
said it quite so simply aren't you tired
of this yes we are tired of this yeah of
course most of Fox News disagrees with
what needs to be done in order to try to
resolve the situation good for her
sounds weird to say right place right
time because the the right place is not
really being a block away from a
shooting that's extremely dangerous but
the right place right time to at least
get that out on national television and
absolutely good for her they want to ban
all sorts of stuff but it's all the
wrong things and we're going to continue
covering it we'll take a break and be
back with plenty more right after this
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
failed former president Donald Trump
gave an interview so bad last night to
Fox News propagandist Sean Hannity so
depraved so visibly disoriented that
even Republicans are saying dude that
was not good we're going to look at the
comments of Republicans in a moment but
let's first look at what happened in the
interview again the interview handled by
Trump's I guess friend at least at one
point friend to the extent Trump has
friends Fox News propaganda Sean Hannity
and Trump spent much of the interview
equivocating about the threat of
violence against Manhattan D.A Alvin
Bragg that he posted a few days ago and
attacking Ron DeSantis neither of which
played particularly well with anybody
here Sean Hannity asks Trump about that
death and destruction post and then the
other one showing him holding a bat next
to Alvin Bragg and Trump kind of plays
dumb but his explanation is also
completely unintelligible so will all
this information that came out in your
favor
you talked about death and destruction
and then you the baseball bat picture
yeah next to Alvin Breg and you did take
that down
and my only question is why open
yourself up to criticism you have to
understand that when the story was put
up I put up a story we didn't see
pictures we put up a story that was very
exculpatory very good story from the
standpoint of what we're talking about
what
and they put up a picture of me and you
know where I was holding the baseball
bat it was at the White House make
America buy America because they did a
lot of buy America things so I guess
he's saying because the source photo of
the bat wasn't actually him standing
next to Alvin Bragg it's no big deal and
this is a company that makes baseball
bats then they put next to that picture
a picture of Alvin Bragg I didn't do it
they did it the the I guess the people
that do the paper or somebody put
pictures together but I was holding a
baseball someone put pictures together
but in order to promote Maiden it wasn't
on your post the truth no no what they
did is we posted the story but they had
a picture up and they then put a picture
up or the picture was put up that nobody
noticed or saw or that nobody thought
was bad these were two isn't this
Crystal Clear separate pictures I was
promoting made in America you make these
baseball bats instead of sending over to
Japan and China and all other places
where they're made this was a company
good company that makes baseball bats
and other things like that in America
they took that picture from the White
House and they put it up and then they
put a picture of Alvin brega okay so of
course we know nobody has alleged that
Trump was actually next to Alvin Bragg
holding a bat to his head the issue is
Trump
publicized the compilation image of
trump holding a bat next to Alvin Bragg
now in this next click clip Trump seems
to say well when we published it there
was no picture and later the picture
appeared let me be clear so you did not
post the picture of you with a baseball
bat in the Oval Office next to the
picture with Bragg somebody else I
posted a very positive article yeah and
whatever picture they put up they put up
my people didn't put up the picture I
think the picture maybe was
either in the article or was put in the
article later okay so anyway Trump
posted it to Troth Central and uh he
seems very much confused about how the
internet works Trump then talked about
his rally over the weekend which we
covered yesterday in Waco Texas Trump
wildly claims that there were in reality
sixty thousand people there now there
were 3 500 people there but Trump says
60. well I deal with it we're dealing
with very dishonest people we're dealing
with thugs we're dealing with people I
actually believe that hate our country
right uh last night I had a rally with
tens of thousands of people like the
Press admitted there were okay so he
says tens of tens of thousands 25 or 30
000 people that the Press admitted there
were 25 or 30 and then here's the
Whopper and you can double it at least
in Texas Waco Texas right so the Press
admits there were 25 to 30 000 and so
the real number is double which is 60
000. there were 3 500 people there maybe
five thousand that's it and this is a
lie as old as Trump's political career
you just make up numbers about the
number of people at your events and the
truth of course is like you and I know
that the number of people at an event
doesn't actually tell us much about how
much of the country supports Trump trump
might have had 3 000 or 20 000 people it
happened to be 3 500 but imagine that he
had twenty thousand that still doesn't
mean that he would win an election or
that he won in 2020 or whatever the case
may be but Trump and people around him
see the number of people at one rally as
some kind of proxy to his totality of
support in a country of 340 million
Trump then claimed that he would solve
the Russian invasion of Ukraine in a day
but he definitely can't explain how
because then his enemies would know his
plan World War one and World War II
looked like Patty Cakes okay uh this
unbelievable because we have people that
don't know what they're doing but if
it's not solved I will have it solved in
24 hours with zelinski and with Putin
right and there's a very easy
negotiation to take place but I don't
want to tell you what it is because then
I can't use that negotiation it'll never
work but there's a very easy negotiation
to take place I will have it within one
day right first day in office Trump
would I mean that's as realistic as he's
going to solve the israeli-palestinian
conflict in the first term he's going to
build the Mexico wall where Mexico will
pay for it none of it's believable this
is as unbelievable as anything else then
we get to what is for some people the
Crux of this interview
DeSantis and Trump really going after
DeSantis and this is what a lot of
Republicans didn't like starts with
Hannity just asking I thought you guys
were friends and Trump says no we were
never friends
question I'm asked most about about you
of late is Rhonda Santos right this is
the question
what happened
I thought they were friends
what happened not friends I didn't know
him well but he was on impeachment okay
so Trump says and then they cut uh he
says we were not friends and I didn't
really know the guy then we really get
into the meat of it and Trump again
telling this story of when Ron DeSantis
came to Trump with tears in his eyes and
again I continue to be shocked that the
number of grown men sobbing around
Donald Trump something about Trump makes
big tough guys SOB so what happened with
Ron is the following he came to see me
he was getting killed he was being
crushed Adam Putnam it was over I have
many people that I know that worked for
Adam Putnam they said it was like a new
thing I hate to use this expression it
was like a nuclear weapon went off when
you endorsed because they considered the
race to be over they had the race he had
millions and millions of dollars and he
was way up in the polls he was meeting
Ron by 30 points or said it was over
Ron came to see me tears in his eyes he
said I need you to do me a big favor
yeah first he asked for the meeting then
he asked me for the favor crying I said
what's the favor
would you endorse me
I fought for you and but again he a lot
of people fought for me you fought for
me only rightfully but you fought for me
if you thought I was right right a lot
more than he did
but he said I need your endorsement
I said Ron you so far behind I can't
imagine does anyone believe this story
if you've got George Washington's
endorsement combined with the great late
great Abraham Lincoln if you had their
endorsements I don't think you could win
run but
tell me about it go ahead he said I'm
telling you I think I could win if I
could get your endorsement and he was
you'll have to check the records but
many many points it was over and the
nomination just very close the
nomination was just okay
I gave I said let's give it a shot okay
you know you defended me Adam Putnam
didn't one way or the other I think he's
probably a nice guy you know I never met
him until later a year later I met him
he said when you did that it was like a
rocket went up he said my race was over
they were already buying furniture for
the for the Governor's Mansion they were
going to win all right so anyway Trump
saying DeSantis cried to him uh and then
that's uh and the rest is history and
then lastly Trump claiming that DeSantis
would be making pizza if it weren't for
Trump then I had him get him I had to
get him against the star of the Democrat
Party was going to be Stacey Abrams and
they now we call him a crackhead because
that's what he was a crackhead and then
kill him kill him and there was no way
Ron was going to beat Gillum so he got
the nomination but there was no way
because this guy was going to be the
future of the Democrat Party uh and I
said Ron you can beat this guy let's go
I got him the nomination by the way
couldn't have never gotten the
nomination he would be working in either
a pizza parlor place or a law office
right now okay there you go he would be
either in a pizza parlor or a law office
which isn't that bad I mean I think that
those are two very different careers a
lot law office or pizza parlor but
needless to say Trump is responsible
deranged visibly confused and
disoriented Trump but most importantly
more and more Republicans don't like
this
after Donald Trump gave this interview
to Sean Hannity last night
a number of Republicans including even
on Fox news said this is not so good
this is not so good first example is
former Republican Congressman Jason
Chaffetz also a current Fox contributor
who says this was a very bad interview
Trump gave a bad interview uh Jason you
said overall you thought president Trump
did a very poor job in the interview why
uh I thought Sean Hannity did a good job
um but I watched that and I thought
where is Donald Trump I I voted for
Donald Trump twice I have defended him
countless times I thought he was
horrific I think that was the worst
interview I've seen the president do he
was whining he was complaining
um he does that in every interview but
it was particularly bad the victim card
time and time again
um and then after that he complained
that you know somebody had endorsed was
now running against him and I I thought
he was absolutely horrific he's the
former president of the United States
act like it he didn't in that interview
wow wow and then even Brian Kilmeade
when he weighed in about it one of the
hosts of fox and friends this morning
saying you know he's kind of punching
down and he really should not do that
and as far as kill Mead goes this is
about as strong of a criticism of trump
as you will ever hear
Bob Dole and George Bush 41 want to tear
each other's eyes out John McCain and
George W bush never really got over the
personal animosity as they locked horns
uh you could say that Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton it got extremely
personal and they've never been closed
since even though they work together for
a short period of time so this is not
unusual but a usual attack on Ron
DeSantis would be I respect him from
what he's done but I'm the one with
International experience I'm the one
that did the Abraham Accords I'm the one
that made NATO pay up to 10 I'm the one
that made sure that Ukraine wasn't
invaded I'm I mean a lot of those things
are lies but okay gave them weapons to
defend themselves not MREs so you point
energy yeah it seems to me the tactic
more traditionally would be yeah around
at 44 years old he's done a lot but look
at what I have done in four years and
these are the same players I like to go
back and finish the job and he's been
very nice thank you Haley I think he's
been deferential to Mike Pompeo uh and
Tim Scott I can't imagine saying
something bad about Tim Scott but with
uh Ron DeSantis he sees a threat but I
think that his best offense as the front
run would be don't punch down don't
punch down says Brian kill me so listen
this is the start this is the start
and we will see if it continues of some
Republicans saying this entire obsession
with the santis thing the attacks the
criticisms the punching down as Brian
Kilmeade calls it the whining is Jason
Chaffetz called it this isn't good for
Trump now I think the Counterpoint to
this is that Trump is so far ahead and
despite allegedly facing an imminent
arrest he is polling more and more
strongly against DeSantis who meanwhile
is on a book tour and getting tons of
favorable press and softball interviews
and DeSantis polling is decreasing so
while I agree with the criticism I don't
know that Republicans care about Trump
whining and punching down and all of the
things that he's doing and also it
doesn't seem like they are flocking to
DeSantis in the way that at one moment
it was predicted that they would the
next step is is Ron DeSantis going to
run or isn't he
if anything the recent polling over the
last 10 to 14 days declining might get
DeSantis to reconsider but we're going
to watch it some Republicans not at all
pleased with this latest disoriented
interview on Fox news by Trump
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
it's great to Welcome to the program
today Tess Wilkinson Ryan who's a moral
psychologist and a law professor at the
University of Pennsylvania and also
author of The recently released book
foolproof how fear of playing the sucker
shapes ourselves and the social order
and what we can do about it really great
having you on today I appreciate your
time
for having me so to start with let's
talk maybe about what is the sucker
construct or or that idea that you talk
about and elaborate in the book
the the soccer construct is the idea
that there are a whole bunch of
interactions or sort of Dynamics
transactions in our everyday lives that
take the shape or can take the shape of
a scam that feel like wait a minute I
have a concern here that I'm about to or
or I have I'm about to sort of
voluntarily enter into something that's
going to leave me holding the bag it's
going to leave me with some unfair bad
results
thus making me a sucker and the reason
for thinking about this as a construct
is that it can sort of be overlaid on a
variety of situations it's not odd
always obvious that you have like a
Ponzi scheme going on
what sorts of situations that might not
be obvious right like outside of actual
Ponzi schemes would this be relevant
are cases where you've gone to buy
something and the price is higher than
you thought it should be
um so I give an example in the book of
my sister going to buy a Gatorade from a
place that she really just realized when
she went in was a tourist trap and sort
of had this moment of being like you
know I'm not one of these people who
pays six dollars for Gatorade but she
was like actually really thirsty and
actually needed to get a gatorade ASAP
and she realized wait what am I doing
there's no reason for me to think I'm a
sucker here I just need to buy this
drink and move along other situations
that come up in everyday life would be
like um deciding whether or not to
believe somebody who's giving you an
excuse for something
um deciding whether to let someone cut
in front of you in traffic
um I think there's a lot of these little
Dynamics where people sort of get their
hackles up and think like what does it
make me if I let you you know whatever
Zoom down the breakdown lane and then
pop in front of me on the highway and
one of the arguments that you make and
that seems quite reasonable is that this
fear of being the sucker impacts
personal all choices where if we had
maybe a more default belief that getting
suckered wasn't a possibility we would
behave differently than having this sort
of guard up what are the sorts of
personal choices that people would make
based on this fear of being suckered
sides of the yeah
I think about this as impacting
decisions that about that are about like
getting ahead and then impacting
decisions that are more like other
regarding so how you sort of do good
rather than yeah sort of how you be good
in the world I guess so one example
would be say personal investing so
um there's actually a really nice study
that sort of asks people
um that asks people in two different
conditions of an experiment how much
money would you invest in this company
if I gave you the stats of this company
and the stats of the company are either
look there's an 80 chance that investors
Break Even 15 chance that investors
double their money or a five percent
chance that they lose it all
and the five percent chance was this was
described to half the subject as a five
percent chance that the founders of the
company
um didn't they had underestimated sorry
they'd overestimated consumer demand
they made a mistake honest mistake
honest mistake exactly yeah so you can
see where it's going right so the other
half of the subjects are told there's a
five percent that five percent chance
that that five percent downside risk
that's the risk of these guys are frauds
um
and you know the numbers there are the
same
in right in both cases is a 95 chance of
breaking even or doing better than
breaking even but people had really
different responses to what to do in
those situations people were way less
willing to invest in the maybe fraud
situation even though only a five
percent risk I guess the difference if
you wanted to argue that there is some
logic to that difference would be well
if they are frauds then we're definitely
not getting our return whereas if
they're wrong we might just get a
different return or market conditions
might change or I mean I get like it's
set up in a way where you're trying to
eliminate that but there are there would
be some argument like that I guess no
and I think that that what you're
describing is actually exactly how this
works psychologically like I think you
are you're exactly right to think that
the way it works is that once you invoke
the fraud possibility people basically
have a whole bunch of ways that that
sort of fraud reasoning
affects the way they think about the
numbers right they think well the fraud
number is really bad that one's serious
the other number doesn't feel as serious
right the kinds of reasons that you
describe and you can think about the
ideas like how how prone are people to
fighting the hypo right they're sort of
like what's happening in the is that
you're sort of resisting the math which
is I think exactly what people are doing
in the real world saying well wait the
math doesn't feel as bad to me right and
part of the argument is like that's
exactly that's exactly the point the
math feels worse once you invoke the
possibility of a scam rather than just a
mistake yeah that's an interesting one
what was the other example from a
different area
yeah the other example is I think that
um people that a lot of people find
pretty intuitive is that people can get
really
um nervous or wary about feeling like a
sucker when they start to get in in when
they're engaging in basically like a
charitable transaction
so if you've ever heard of if you've
ever heard people
um sort of resisting donating money or
resisting even giving money to somebody
who's asking for money in on the street
for example and they say well what are
they going to spend it on right and
there's a sort of but what does it make
me if they're gonna spend this money on
something that I don't approve of right
that's sort of a consistent fear
um and there's a whole bunch of
um sort of
asked me a while so there's a whole
bunch of please for example from
um food banks yes
and the food banks say we we really
appreciate donations but please donate
cash
cash is what we need because we know
what the needs are of the people who are
serving we don't pay retail prices right
we pay wholesale prices
um and we can
um and and we can um buy things in bulk
and a lot of people really resist
donating cash
it's a lot easier I think to raise to um
to do a charity drive where you're
asking for in-kind donations you know
toys coats food cans of of you know
canned goods rather than cash and
there's some really interesting studies
that suggest that people basically feel
like well cash is so easy to abuse cash
is going to you know if I give cash I'd
be worried what people are going to do
with it whereas if I give a can of
beans
there's only so many things you can do
with that yeah exactly it's kind of
exploitation proof right yeah yeah yeah
um
right so it's sort of exploitation proof
and
I know it I I can see how people can
sort of justify that in their minds like
what's going on there
but actually for any individual if I was
gonna donate let's say say food to a
food drive for me to take to get into my
car right and drive to a store and pay
retail prices for a bunch of rice and
beans and then to bring them to the food
bank is actually a huge waste of time
and money and for all I know they need
baby formula right without raising beans
and so it's actually a way of making
this donation way less valuable and way
less and way more costly for me when it
comes to um I mean we're sort of kind of
getting into some stereotyping of like
what would the folks who are on the
receiving end be likely to do if they
received a versus B can you talk a
little more generally about how
stereotyping plays a role in the sucker
construct
yeah I think
I think appreciated
actually maybe I want to flip the
question a little bit and argue that
the ideas we have and the fears we have
about playing the sucker are actually
constitutive of a lot of Intergroup
stereotypes a lot of the most pernicious
sort of avenues of bias in the in the
culture so if you think for so the
example I've raised about
um about the donations
this is a place where I think a lot of
people can see that we live in a society
where there are stereotypes for example
about people living in poverty right
right that actually what they're doing
is taking your taxpayer dollars and
using them to avoid entering the
workforce
those kinds of stereotypes
are leveraged to basically reduce
solidarity I would say right to sort of
like to come between people who want to
do the compassionate thing and the
compassionate or the sensible or the
Humane or however you want to describe
it to come between them and that
instinct and sort of create Rifts
between people and it does seem to
follow from that belief that if you
believe that you would say well by
donating the cans rather than the money
I am acting logically based on this
stereotype about the group that would
receive it
people to whom you are donating Goods or
money right the more you'll go out of
your way to only make a very particular
kind of donation
um and I mean and I would sort of still
argue that's a that is still sort of at
its core an inefficient donation
um in part because
it there's not actually I mean in part
because the The Stereotype content is
we don't have reason to believe it's
true right I think it's you know it's
it's bringing in a bunch of sort of
pernicious classism basically when we
think about different types of so you
know there's like hustles scams Ponzi
schemes business practices to some
degree you know we were recently talking
about the FTC now is looking at passing
a law that says you have to be able to
cancel a gym membership in the same way
that you sign up for it right so it
can't be you sign up in 30 seconds
online but then you've got to go in in
person with a notarized form in order to
cancel it if that's how you have to
cancel it then you've got to sign up
that way which would never happen
because the whole point is reduce
friction for the sign up increase
fiction for for the cancellation that's
like a business practice which you can
argue is a sort of hustle or scam but
people's sort of uh uh resistance to it
is very different than someone on the
street asking for money what's happening
psychologically there
yeah it's a great question I so and I
should say that the gym example is like
very close to my heart in part because
my you know day job on teaching
contracts and so I do a lot of my
research about consumer contracts and
the way people interact with this whole
world of sort of clicking to clicking to
to agree yeah and one of my deep
concerns about the way that consumer
contracts operate in the world is that
people do feel like they are bound to
these deals and sort of don't perceive
them as these as exploitation in the way
that you might expect given how hard it
is to get out of your gym membership
right right that kind of thing
um so so part of the argument that I'm
that um that you're picking up on is the
argument that
it feels worse to be taken advantage of
by someone who you thought was your
subordinate or peer than someone who you
already assumed had a bunch of power so
if you think that a scam is a power play
and I think it is I think I think
there's a lot about it's about power in
part right when if you feel like you've
been scammed one of the experiences you
have is a feeling as a feeling sort of
foolish and humiliated right it's sort
of a low status it's a it's a lowering
of your sense of like
what my belonging in this group my sense
of dignity and belonging right okay
being able to be made to feel that way
by someone who you already assumed had
power or or you feel I should say you
feel less I feel you feel as acutely if
it's coming from someone who you already
thought was sort of making the world go
around
whereas if you think about as people who
you thought were
um who you assumed were sort of in
positions of less power than you and it
feels like you've been kicked down
further on the sort of social ladder in
ways that feel really terrible right in
ways I feel like destabilizing like what
is my sense of status and belonging in
the in this community that's interesting
and and that you know when I think about
35 overdraft fees on a checking account
which might add up to 500 bucks versus
someone suckered you out of 500 worth of
bitcoin the latter is sort of a someone
just like you who figured out a way to
get 500 in Bitcoin from you versus
something that seems more systematic and
sort of like a business oriented
transaction where you could argue I mean
I'm not saying that you're told the
overdraft fees up front like I
understand that it's not exactly the
same but the feeling would come away
being dramatically different yeah I
think if that's right I think people
feel like there's a there's a theory in
Psychology that I like that I like a lot
called
um system justification and it's just
the idea basically is people are sort of
motivated to explain that the system
works right so you're motivated to say
like well you know the banks have to
make their money somehow and I did I
knew you know I was alerted beforehand I
was gonna hit his overdraft fee even
though so even though just to be clear
my own my argument is like no that's
deeply problematic like in fact nobody
can read all these terms and conditions
it's right this is having all of these
sort of fines and fees be associated
with this sort of culture of scolding
people about reading the fine print I
think is super cynical yeah
but I think you're right that when it
comes from like as you say like a peer
like someone who's sort of like
leveraged their position to get one over
on you even though you're both just
people out there in the crypto world if
it feels like yeah I've been like I sort
of have been like demoted in this social
World last thing I want to ask you about
in terms of like foolproofing ourselves
so that we can't be scammed in specific
areas you can always find Tips when it
comes to those phishing emails here's
the way that you handle that when you go
to buy a car don't let them make the
conversation about your monthly payment
like first talk about the sale price
then deal with fine you know there's
within specific areas there's all these
ideas are there more overarching
principles or are they really the types
of principles that lend themselves to
paranoia and are less useful practically
speaking
yeah
you know in some ways I have like this
this deeply unsatisfying answer to that
question which is kind of like that part
of the view of the part of my view is is
to
surrender more often to let it be that
in that there are more cases in which
you have thought through what were the
consequences in this case be of of being
sort of a little bit duped or scammed or
whatever
and if they aren't that big to just let
it go right I think the the context that
you're describing like buying a car
that's exactly the kind of context where
you want to be really have your antennae
up right you want to be like especially
wary the stakes are certainly higher
hi and you know the only goal is to get
out of there with a car that you can
afford it's not like you you don't have
a goal of like making friends with a
salesperson right but there are all
these other contexts in life where you
can sort of get this kind of Sucker
prickle at the back you know like oh is
this gonna happen to me that happened I
mean so for example in the life of a
teacher that's me right in the in your
life as a parent as a friend
where you start to get that that little
prickle and it really helps to think
well wait a minute what actually is the
risk here how big of a deal would it be
if I gave a student an extension on a
paper but they didn't technically need
for the reason they said that they
needed right that would probably be to
be a small deal by contrast it would
feel like a really big deal if I treated
a student callously who actually needed
my help right right it's about like
weighing the real risks and sort of
going back to that investment example
right of like asking yourself to talk
through the math a little bit to say is
it right do I really think that that my
sort of focus on this you know risk of a
fraudster is something that I believe in
in some deeper way or is this a little
mistake I'm making a sort of a way my
attention's been
been torn away from the place where it
really belongs yeah and that the example
about the paper and the extension also
relates to an asymmetry in if I'm
correctly assessing versus incorrectly
assessing and that that certainly can be
a big factor as well the book is
foolproof how fear of playing the sucker
shapes ourselves and the social order
and what we can do about it we've been
speaking with the book's author
Professor Tess Wilkinson Ryan really
appreciate your time and your insights
today
this was great
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show you know
the last week or so I've been thinking
to some degree it seems as though
so-called wokeness is actually the
prevailing opinion in a way it seems as
though wokeness is winning in the United
States and Eugene Robinson from The
Washington Post wrote a really great
piece yesterday called wokeness is
winning and it makes some excellent
points backed by facts which I'm going
to get to in a moment but when I I
started to suspect that this entire
anti-woke Framing and campaign and
Obsession from the right maybe a bit of
an overplay of the hand that they are uh
that they are currently playing was
polling out of Florida
that a lot of Ron desantis's extreme
anti-woke stuff could potentially
backfire because by and large a majority
of the country seems to sympathize with
the woke perspectives even when defined
as woke now there's two different things
here okay let me give you an analogy
when we talk about health care you could
say the government has a duty to provide
a basic level of care to everybody
regardless of ability to pay very high
support for that claim on the other hand
if you say there should be a government
takeover of your health care
very low support for that claim but
when we actually dissect what do we mean
here and accurately represent what
things are we see that people generally
tend to agree more than they disagree
with the left-wing perspective on Health
Care the government does have a basic
duty to provide an entry level of care
at minimum to everybody if you say to
people are you in favor of wokeness
versus if you say Do you think that it's
important to promote equality of
opportunity and accept people who are
trans and businesses should take steps
to promote diversity when you ask people
about those individual issues there is
significant support for them but then
you go well what about woke are you woke
much lower level of support
case in point in Eugene Robinson's piece
in the Washington Post
he talks about a survey that was
conducted by the nonpartisan Research
Institute norc at the University of
Chicago they do a lot of different
opinion polling and we often cite them
on the show
they looked at actual so-called woke
issues and found that the woke side of
the equation is way more popular than
you might think based on what you see on
Fox news or elsewhere on the issue of
quote accepting people who are
transgender
56 percent of respondents said either
Society has been about right or hasn't
gone far enough when it comes to
accepting people who are trans the woke
positions are a majority the minority
thinks that acceptance of trans people
has gone too far another example on the
issue of promoting equality between men
and women
86 percent of respondents say that
Society is either where it should be or
hasn't gone far enough to promote
equality between men and women that's a
woke country
by their term now of course woke as a
pejorative is used to criticize these
positions but the point here is when you
ask people about their views on issues
they very much are in favor unquote
accepting people who are gay lesbian or
bisexual the poll found that 69 percent
of respondents believe that Society has
been well calibrated on promoting
acceptance or has not gone far enough
that is very woke and then lastly on
businesses taking steps to promote
racial and ethnic diversity woke beats
anti-woke 70 to 28 even when you ask
about schools and universities taking
steps to promote racial and ethnic
diversity again wokeness wins 67 to 30.
last aspect to this specifically about
schools in the context of banning drag
shows and banning books and all of it
when respondents were asked
which of these concerns you more about
schools today given the choice of two
statements are you more concerned about
schools Banning books and censoring
topics of educational importance or are
you more concerned about uh um are you
in favor of uh schools doing that and
concerned that inappropriate things may
be taught to your kids by an almost two
to one margin
people are more concerned about the
Banning of books and the limiting of
teaching in schools rather than oh my
kid might be taught something
inappropriate so there's a couple of
important takeaways from this number one
as another reminder Reddit and Twitter
aren't real life in the sense that ideas
can be over or underrepresented in those
spheres
and when you actually talk to people
just out there you get dramatically
different results and number two
even the concerted effort of how has it
been a year has it been two years three
years it's kind of all the time work but
certainly we've seen one to three years
of a concerted effort to go after a lot
of these same elements
despite all of that it hasn't been that
effective at actually convincing people
to take so-called anti-woke positions
which I would call in many cases just
anti-science positions and so for
someone like Iran DeSantis who's about
Florida is where woke comes to die and
on and on and on it may help him in the
Republican primary in some states not
necessarily even all but it may not be
super useful nationally if he were to
win the nomination Ron DeSantis that is
in running against the eventual
Democratic nominee because it still
seems that even after a blitz of one to
three years just attacking these views
in these positions most Americans
actually come down on what is often
characterized as the woke position
will be an interesting thing to see in
24 when it comes to strategy
I meant to play this earlier in the week
and I wasn't able to get to it and I
don't want to skip over it because it is
so strange and interesting Donald Trump
put out a statement about how he helped
the farmers avoid an estate tax but in
the discussion of it he talks about how
if you don't love your kids you don't
have to leave them your farm and it has
a very weird undertone where many people
saw this and speculated and wrote To Me
is This Trump signaling he doesn't love
his kids and he's not leaving them his
an inheritance it is very strange I want
you to take a look at this and tell me
what you think and I made farmers happy
and Rich again
and they're doing a fantastic job
and you know what
someday it'll become time for them to
leave this beautiful Earth
and they'll be able to leave their Farm
without taxes all right okay so far I
understand the policy to their children
I got rid of the death tax on farms
so that when you do pass away
on the assumption that you love your
children
you can leave it to them and they won't
have to pay tax
but if you don't love your children so
much and there are some people that
don't and maybe deservedly so it won't
matter because frankly you don't have to
leave them anything thank you very much
have fun have fun with that guys huh our
friend Aaron rupar on Twitter said that
he had to watch this two times merely to
convince himself that it wasn't some
kind of deep fake AI prank because it's
so bizarre so a couple different things
here first of all it sort of seems like
this is being written into Trump's
scripts because he said something very
similar on March 13th in Iowa and he
said it in an almost identical way and
then of course the bigger question that
many of you are wondering about is is
this Donald Trump signaling something to
his own children is this Donald Trump
signaling that that maybe it is he who
doesn't love his kids it's absolutely
bizarre and strange and the focus now
multiple times on people who don't love
their kids really strange stuff
I don't know what to make of it let me
know in the comments what you think we
have a voicemail number that number is
219 to David P
in this voicemail our longtime caller
the Eggman
has a suggestion for me and I want you
to weigh in on his suggestion the Eggman
says David
don't even bother covering the shootings
anymore just don't even bother because
nobody's willing to do anything these
Republicans won't do a damn thing about
it it's just a waste of your breath yes
another one and another one and they're
tragic but what else is there to do
listen to the Eggman say it
hey Dave regarding the shooting at the
Nashville uh Christian private school
three children killed three adults
killed um
don't even discuss it skip right over it
I think that liberals and Democrats are
just wasting our time talking about all
these gun violence and murders and try
to change gun laws it's gonna literally
do nothing I'm listening to the mayor
speak and he's acting like oh now things
are going to change this is the same
thing every time
don't waste one second on this story
focus on something that will actually
help we will never change guns the
murders will never stop the only way
they'll stop is when they kill
themselves with their own guns so
it's at a complete waste of time in my
opinion to even discuss these shootings
we should act like they're not even
happening
Shalom what do you think what do you
think does the Eggman have a point I
mean it what he's right about is
it's a circle and it's an endless Circle
and of course this could just be a show
about mass shootings I mean okay
yesterday we had the shooting in
Nashville Tennessee which I covered and
there was a mass shooting in Milwaukee
Wisconsin and then on Sunday there were
mass shootings in Philadelphia
Minneapolis Little Rock Arkansas and
Minden Louisiana and then on Saturday
there were mass shootings in Hempstead
New York Williamston North Carolina
Macon Illinois and Shreveport Louisiana
and then Friday there was another mass
shooting in Shreveport Louisiana so the
the point is every day we could be
talking about these mass shootings
Eggman says even if you don't talk about
them at all or you do talk about them
nothing is going to change
so then what's the point asks the Eggman
I've laid out 10 to 12 bullet points I
talked about it at the top of the show
of of rules and laws and policies that
could be put in place to reduce the
number of mass shootings there's no
willingness whatsoever from Republicans
to Institute even a single one of them
so what is it that we are doing when we
acknowledge these tragedies and of
course we only acknowledge some of them
some of them make the national news and
some of them don't I don't have the
answer quite frankly I'm not pretending
to have the answer but I understand and
sympathize with the eggman's frustration
my question to you
is should these be covered because it
seems strange not to seems strange to
pretend that there is no mass shooting
problem in the United States
at the same time I understand that we've
been covering these things for over a
decade and very little has changed let
me know what you think we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today we're
going to talk about the new overt
what would we call it recruiting
campaign by Republicans for Senate
candidates that are genuinely Filthy
Rich why is this what they're doing and
what way are they doing it we'll talk
about it secondly is Michelangelo's
David
pornography there are some Florida
parents who say that it is and Italians
are inviting the Florida parents to come
check it out for themselves and then
lastly a TV anchor named Barbie Bassett
has been fired uh taken off air at least
I believe may be fired we'll double
check after quoting Snoop Dogg during a
broadcast and it was a quote of Snoop
Dogg uh should she have been taken off
air what should the repercussions be did
she do anything wrong an uproar about
this and it is becoming another flash
point
in this contrived culture War we will
talk about all sides of it when producer
Pat joins me on today's bonus show oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money yep everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad right
let's go make some money on the bonus
show okay you can sign up at
joinpakman.com coupon code 24 starts now
for a discount every single day after
this show there's the bonus show and we
can all be thankful for that
thank you